- Some of the ways that
Ultima was quite unique
back in the 1980s was that you would start
through creating a character.
Your character would even
have attributes like strength
and dexterity and stamina.
Whatever it might be.
It had the characters and the story.
It had places where once
you had gone out on a battle
and fought that you can return to.
A city or a town where you
could replenish your supplies,
rest up, heal up.
Those sort of things.
And so I sort of saw it as a world.
A living, breathing fantasy
universe to play as a player.
- [Narrator] In an industry
that had always assigned
players a character to play,
a game like Ultima
allowed you to build one.
It created an open world where
you could then venture forth
on epic quests and equip different weapons
and armor to aid you on your adventure.
- With Ultima, in a very real way,
I was finally beginning
to flex a little bit
of those game master roots.
(suspenseful music)
You're now being involved in a narrative
where I have laid out the
fundamentals of the narrative
but a lot of the details are
filled in by you the player.
(suspenseful music)
- [Narrator] To be brutally honest,
the game hasn't aged gracefully.
But without this, you wouldn't have these.
(dramatic music)
In a short period of time,
creators like Richard and
Roberta had taken computer games
from simple text on
screen to crude graphics,
to character creation.
The genre was evolving.
Trying to perfect itself
within the limits of technology
and building upon each innovation.